once the explosion takes place the shock
wave goes past you
then you're gonna have to watch out for
a flying frag which could definitely
kill you
i'm jocko willink and this is the
[Music]
breakdown
[Music]
this is tears of the sun
the term seal actually stands for sea
air and land and what that means is that
we can use any of those mediums to
get to a target this is a movie about
seals going into another country to
rescue someone that is being held
against their will that is something
that can happen it can happen on a small
scale where you're going to
rescue one or two people and it also
happens sometimes on a larger scale
let's say a country is being overthrown
or there's a coup
and a lot of americans are in danger
well then the u.s military will spin up
its resources
go in there and conduct a non-combatant
evacuation operation where you take
all the american citizens out of a
country as safely and quickly as
possible it's almost always a factor
that when you do military operations
there's going to be
civilians that you have to interact with
whether they're innocent civilians
or maybe they're compliant with the
enemy that you're dealing with maybe
they're actually sympathizers for the
enemy nonetheless you'll have to deal
with civilians and it looks like they're
dealing with some civilians
in this movie the united states military
and most
militaries around the world go through
great lengths
to protect innocent civilians in a
wartime scenario you
have to be very careful with where
you're shooting you have to positively
identify your target
you have to make sure that when you're
conducting operations you
calculate where the civilians are and
how you're going to contend with them
once the operation starts
terrain is very important in combat and
one of the
early lessons that you learn is using
what's called
cover or concealment concealment is
something that you can hide behind but
it doesn't actually give you protection
from enemy fire
cover is something that you can hide
behind that does give you protection
so you prefer to be able to take cover
but you don't always have that option
your next best option is to get
concealment which means you're in a
position where
the enemy can't see you and maybe aim
their weapon at you so if all you have
the option for
is tall grass like this then that's what
you're to use
when you're out in the field there's all
kinds of things that are
around you they're not always the enemy
so a situation like this
he hears movement out there and it
happens to be a pig
this is something that could happen when
you're moving through a closed terrain
like that hearing is one of your best
senses
and so as you listen you might not be
able to discriminate between what's an
enemy person walking in
in this case a pig you have to try and
pay attention but you still have to
address the threats because you can't be
100 sure of what something is
clear lt it's just a pig i'm crossing
over
sniper 11 o'clock snipers have a very
scary
advantage in a situation like this
you're staring at
270 degrees of pure threat a sniper
has to take one shot and that's what
just happened it'd be
impossible to stop that in this
particular situation
once a guy was wounded one of the other
guys launched a 40 millimeter grenade
into the general area where they thought
the sniper might be and then some other
guys moved forward
to try and start to stabilize this guy
that just been wounded the
thing that's unrealistic it wouldn't
know particularly where this shot had
come from most likely
so what you'd probably be doing in this
case is putting down a heavy volume of
machine gun fire in that general
direction
then moving forward to try and get to
this individual that's been wounded
calvary
he's all right we're on the shoulder
clean hit though so the person that's
taking care of the wounded guy he might
be
the platoon corpsman which is basically
an innocent platoon that's their medic
but also every guy in a seal platoon
knows how to give that first primary
trauma care so it could have been anyone
in his platoon that went up and
stopped the bleeding and got a bandage
on it inside of a seal platoon and
really inside of any
military unit we use standard operating
procedures everyone is gonna have their
medical gear
in the same spot if there's a problem
someone will come up grab your med kit
and start working on you with your med
kit
it looks like they're just throwing some
pressure onto his shoulder to stop some
of the bleeding but it must not be that
bad because he seems to be doing all
right
it looks like they're trying to show
sort of a traditional covered move
they're doing it a little bit backwards
because it looks like the guys when they
get up they're shooting
and then when they lay down they're not
shooting it should be the opposite it
should be when you're down and you can
actually handle your weapon you're
shooting and then when you're up and
moving you're not shooting because you
can't really shoot that accurately
not that you can never shoot when you're
moving but it looks like that's what
they're trying to show here
you see the guys laying down and then
rolling over what they're trying to
simulate is
when you're in a fire fight you don't
want to lay down
and then get back up in the exact same
spot because if the enemy saw you lay
down
they'll be looking for you when you
stand back up and they'll shoot you what
you'll do is
get down and then move so when you stand
back up you're in a different location
whether you're going to do this kind of
crazy looking combat roll
probably not likely you're probably just
going to slide over move over crawl over
to a new location before you get back
up but i guess that wouldn't look as
good for the camera
they're using some grenades in this
scene and grenades are a great weapon
they don't quite provide this massive
impact with people flying through the
air after a grenade goes off but they
are a great weapon to use you do have to
be careful
especially in a jungle environment when
you throw grenades if they hit a tree
branch they could
come back at you and that could be a
real problem so you have to pay
attention to what you're doing we throw
a lot of
real grenades in training and then we
throw also simulated grenades so we get
used to throwing grenades
going through the procedures pulling the
pin keeping the spoon on cooking it off
if you want to
and then hucking that grenade into a
good location let me rewind this part
one thing that they do right there they
actually yell grenade
when they're throwing the grenade which
is not what you do
you don't yell grenade when you throw a
grenade what grenade means when you yell
it is that there's someone threw a
grenade at us
in the seal teams there's a different
word that we yell when we're gonna throw
a grenade
and that's not it a little note but they
probably did it to not give away
some information just like i'm not gonna
say anything else about it
what the nigerians are shooting back at
them are
rpgs rocket-propelled grenades and once
these guys are getting close to the
enemy
they're shooting as they're moving which
is perfectly acceptable
i would say my assessment is that these
individuals probably spent three or four
days on a range with a technical advisor
learning how to shoot the weapons and
then they kind of married that with
their own
vision of what shooting would look like
and what would make it look cool
that's what you end up with
[Music]
once the firefight is over what they
actually need to do is set security and
make sure that they are in a secure
position that the enemy doesn't
flank them or counter-attack before they
go and try and recover
i guess the american that they're
looking for that's the mission that
they're there to execute so they're
going to get that job done
but they should definitely set security
you always got to watch your flanks
next up battleship i would say i
probably played
the game battleship on total of three
times
before i realized i wanted a machine gun
in my hand
[Music]
it doesn't seem really necessary to make
up a movie like this
you know you could look at the american
navy fighting against the japanese
imperial navy in world war ii and you
could get as much drama
and heroics as you could possibly
imagine america has fought fierce
enemies
and we should probably make movies to
remember those efforts
instead of making up these random
science fiction things
as far as my knowledge of fictional
alien weapon systems
i don't know but this weapon system is
supposed to be you know something
similar to an american warship that
locks onto targets using
radar laser rangefinders and a bunch of
other
high-speed technology to locate and fix
on an enemy target
incoming headed for the john paul jones
john paul jones famous quote is don't
give up the ship
and he's got a ship named after him the
john paul jones which is now
under attack by an alien naval vessel
this is dumb i know i'm inbound
vampire killing with sea witch
the fighting of the ship is done from a
place called the combat information
center i think the cic
and that's a room where there's a bunch
of monitors radars
and a bunch of information is being
pumped in there and then people are
making decisions in there
she says something like there's inbound
rounds coming their way he says
verify verify and then he says killing
with sea wiz which the c
whiz is the weapon system which is
shooting a massive amount of rounds
out at an incoming object and again
these are just sort of
what some inexperienced hollywood
screenwriter
thought would sound cool to explain what
was happening in the situation and
fill some verbage in there
the little boat that you're seeing is
called the rib
a rigid hull inflatable boat which
usually launches off of one of these
larger vessels and in this particular
case it's got
a gal mini gun on it which shoots
thousands and thousands of rounds per
minute that's not a normal
armament for a normal fleet rib
but this is a movie and it's not a good
movie so
i guess they put it in there for some
reason
the way that u.s navy ships are built if
there is a breach in one part of the
hole
you can seal that section of the ship
off with big giant waterproof
doors and the whole ship is cut up into
these little sections
so if there's a breech in the hole
somewhere you simply shut the hatches
around that area
and the water can't go any further
if a ship was detonated by alien
weaponry into multiple pieces like this
and you were close
by to it you would have to watch out for
the impact of
fragmentation first there would be a
shock wave which
likely wouldn't hurt you depending on
the enemy armament
but once the explosion takes place the
shock wave goes past you then you're
gonna have to watch out for a flying
frag
which could definitely kill you the only
bigger threat
from the flying frag would be having to
sit through a movie like this
last but not least behind enemy lines
even though this guy is a navy pilot if
he needs to be rescued
from being shot down it's likely going
to be some kind of a search and rescue
in a search and rescue or down pilot
recovery there's a high likelihood that
you're going to use helicopters because
you can launch them you can land very
close to or on top of the down pilot you
can get them on board the helicopters
and leaves the only thing that might
prevent that is
if it was a massive surface to air
threat
then maybe ground troops would have to
walk in
to recover the pilot walk back out and
then get to a point where they could
safely get on board helicopters this is
marine corps helicopters huey
helicopters that have been around since
vietnam
looks like they're going in unescorted
by any attack helicopters but
it's a movie we're gonna deal with it
i've never seen this movie before maybe
what they're trying to show with a
little blinking light is some kind of a
transponder that's signaling the
location
of the downed pilot to aircraft overhead
if it wasn't supposed to be a
transponder
transponders don't make beeping noises
and have red flashing lights
owen wilson's character is a pilot which
means
there's a high likelihood he would not
be traveling with a battle rifle of any
kind
he's going to travel with a pistol just
in case he got shot down
for some reason he took a lot of time to
get in this stealthy position
and trick this sniper to come out into
the open it seems like it would have
been a better idea just to sort of
not make a big show of yourself so that
the sniper would know you were there
and then shoot the sniper in the back
but once again
for purposes of drama he makes this
giant entry into the scene bursting out
of the snow
very excited
people that are pilots don't get a lot
of training
with weapons because they're pilots and
their primary job is flying aircraft
they do get a little bit of time
learning how to shoot guns but it's
definitely not their primary skill set
which is why he just missed this shot
like eight times in a row or whatever if
he was uh
more experienced this scene wouldn't be
very exciting because he would have
tactically
slowly gotten out of his concealed
position and put one round into this
enemy's
head
[Music]
as far as the hand-to-hand combat it's
the same thing
pilots are not going to get a lot of
hand-to-hand combat training
because that is not their primary
secondary or even tertiary mission
i think what we have to hope for is that
this pilot either wrestled or boxed or
did jiu jitsu
at some point in his life
the actual weapon used to kill the enemy
sniper is what appears to be a
flare gun and we do have these little
pencil flares
that are very small they're about the
size of a pencil and
they shoot a very small flare almost
like a tracer round from a bullet
last ditch if someone was flying
overhead you could shoot this thing and
they might be able to see you
it seems like that's what they're trying
to portray that he fires off some kind
of a small flare like that
and then sticks it into the guy's
sternum for the kill shot
i think really what we're hoping is that
owen wilson
focuses more on wes anderson from here
on out that was just the breakdown from
gq
thanks for watching